hallo leute in den letzten tagen haben
wir viele anfragen von euch bekommen zum
thema corona virus in deutschland einige
von euch haben uns auch den vorschlag
gemacht dass wir mal ein video zu diesem
thema machen
und genau das möchte ich heute machen
ein kurzes video indem ich darüber rede
wie die situation aktuell in deutschland
ist welche maßnahmen ist in deutschland
gibt wie wir ganz persönlich damit
umgehen und welche konsequenzen das auch
für easy german haben wird in den
nächsten wochen
los gehts ja wie in vielen anderen
ländern auch ist die situation in
deutschland aktuell ziemlich angespannt
in den letzten tagen gab es immer mehr
fälle des corona virus heute ist montag
der 16
märz wenn ich dieses video aufnehmen und
wir haben jetzt ungefähr 5000 fälle die
ganze situation ist schon lange bekannt
aber tatsächlich haben
erst in den letzten in der letzten woche
sind eigentlich viele maßnahmen
entwickelt worden und neue regeln
aufgestellt worden die die meisten leute
in deutschland betreffen
und so wird das thema auch jetzt erst in
der letzten woche wirklich verstärkt
wahrgenommen
letzte woche wurde zum beispiel
entschieden dass alle veranstaltungen in
deutschland abgesagt werden
alle clubs und bars und kneipen sind
geschlossen und die leute wurden dazu
aufgerufen zu hause zu bleiben
angela merkel hat wörtlich gesagt alle
sozialen kontakte sollen vermieden
werden
und in vielen anderen ländern gibt es
schon drastischere maßnahmen zum
beispiel italien und spanien
dort werden die leute gebeten gar nicht
mehr auf die straße zu gehen das ist in
deutschland noch nicht so leute dürfen
auf die straße gehen sie sollen
allerdings soziale kontakte und
ansammeln
vermeiden und ich zeige euch jetzt mal
wie das hier aus sieht ja hier seht ihr
jetzt einen blick auf die straße hier in
unserer in der umgebung unserer wohnung
und tatsächlich sieht die lage noch
ziemlich entspannt aus menschen gehen
zur arbeit menschen gehen auch noch in
cafés und restaurants
gestern haben wir schon auf der straße
gesehen dass tatsächlich die polizei
herumfährt und restaurants und cafés
kontrolliert denn dort soll es 1,5 meter
mindestabstand geben zwischen den
menschen und das ist natürlich schwierig
umzusetzen zb in kleineren läden wie
döner läden oder imbissen dort sind die
menschen sehr eng zusammen und
tatsächlich kontrolliert die polizei das
jetzt ich persönlich weiß nicht wie
lange diese orte noch auf haben werden
denn bisher sehe ich noch nicht so ein
verantwortungsvolles verhalten der
menschen also die meisten leute gehen
trotzdem in cafés und in alle orte die
noch offen haben und sind dort auch
relativ eng zusammen und ich fürchte
dass die regierung noch stärkere
maßnahmen treffen muss denn viele
menschen sind doch freiwillig ja nicht
alle sind dazu freiwillig zu bewegen
dass sie auch diesen mindestabstand
einheiten ja wie betrifft uns das ganze
persönlich wir persönlich bleiben
tatsächlich schon seit einiger zeit so
gut es geht zu hause das heißt wir
arbeiten von zu hause wir haben
natürlich das glück dass wir das ohnehin
schon immer gemacht haben wir gehen im
moment auch nicht auf die straße um
interviews zu machen und das kann
natürlich auch ein kleines problem für
uns werden da kommen wir später noch zu
und tatsächlich versuchen wir uns an
alle vorgaben zu halten die es gibt denn
auch ich habe in den letzten tagen viel
gelernt und ich sehe auch dass es immer
noch viel unsicherheit gibt natürlich
ist das thema mega stress ich also ich
bin in den letzten tagen auch immer
wieder aufgewacht dachte wow sonnen
schein habe so ein bisschen meine
gedanken sortiert und plötzlich wieder
realisiert mein gott wir leben gerade in
einer krise und das ist wahrscheinlich
einer der größten krisen oder die größte
krise die ich in meinem leben bisher
erlebt habe und viele menschen sind mit
dieser situation überfordert und
überforderung kann auch dazu führen dass
man erst mal ja angst hat oder sachen
einfach ablehnt dass man sich mit
informationen nicht so genau auseinander
setzt das man vielleicht nicht mehr
schlechte nachrichten hören will und
dann gar keine nachrichten gehört und im
zweifelsfall auch dass man das ganze
nicht so ernst nimmt und vor zwei wochen
da gab es auch schon viele warnungen
aber ich muss zugeben dass ich dass da
auch noch nicht so ernst genommen habe
und viele sachen noch ein bisschen
lächerlich fand oder dachte dass
menschen mit panik reagieren und das hat
sich tatsächlich geändert also ich muss
zugeben dass ich auch ziemlich viel
gelernt habe in den letzten tagen auch
dank meiner freunde und familie die mir
bestimmte artikel geschickt haben
und ich nehme die situation mittlerweile
sehr ernst und hoffe auch dass ihr das
tut also die ja dieses ganze konzept
dass man soziale kontakte vermeiden soll
ist tatsächlich der einzige weg wie wir
es vielleicht schaffen können diesen
großen ausbruch etwas zu verlangsamen
wir sehen bereits jetzt in italien zum
beispiel wie die situation dort ist dass
die krankenhäuser überfüllt sind und
auch bei uns wird es in den nächsten
tagen zu einem rasanten anstieg kommen
also es kann sein dass es in zehn tagen
schon 50.000 infizierte gibt und dann
bis zu 100.000 das ist auch gar nicht
schwer auszurechnen denn es ist einfach
eine exponentielle kurve und jeden tag
steigen im moment die zahlen
und irgendwann steigt das dann eben
nicht mehr um ein paar hundert leute
sondern um ein paar tausend um ein paar
zehntausend und die situation wird eben
nicht mehr zu kontrollieren seien
deswegen bleiben wir zu hause und ich
hoffe ihr auch und ich zeige euch jetzt
mal wie wir die zeit hier nutzen
als erstes werde ich mal janisch
besuchen und schauen was der so macht
[Musik]
ich weiß total nicht was ich tue
ok also ich hab mir gerade dieses
spielzeug gekauft es ist ein controller
das heißt er dadurch kontrolliere ich
das was ich in meinen musikprogramm habe
meine fragen wer jetzt betrifft ich die
korona krise persönlich ja ich fühle
mich fast schuldig weil sie wirklich
privilegiert sind wir dürfen wir können
wir können es uns leisten zu hause zu
bleiben und so der gefahr weitgehend aus
dem weg zu gehen
aber es gibt menschen die mitten drin
sind ob das die polizisten sind ärzte
und krankenpfleger krankenpflegerinnen
und respekt also leute haltet euch fest
und passt auf euch auf und wir sehen uns
dann spätestens auf youtube bei unserer
letzten ja was bedeutet das jetzt alles
für easy german tatsächlich können wir
im moment nicht mehr auf der straße
interviews machen das heißt wir werden
in der nächsten zeit ein paar andere
videoformate ausprobieren also macht
euch keine sorgen wir sind hier und wir
sind auch produktiv und wollen die zeit
nutzen ein paar andere interessante
dinge für euch zu machen und ich hoffe
dass ihr auch produktiv bleibt und eure
gute laune versucht zu behalten
es ist wichtig dass man in dieser zeit
produktiv ist und versucht das beste aus
der situation zu machen und ich
persönlich versuche zum beispiel viel in
kontakt zu bleiben menschen anzurufen
das ist eine ganz gute zeit auch mal
menschen anzurufen mit dem man schon
länger nicht mehr gesprochen hat wenn
man sowieso nicht rausgehen kann
und ja ich versuche auch eine disziplin
zu halten
ein guter arbeitsdisziplin zu haben weil
das hilft einem auch dass man ein
bisschen ja klar im kopf bleibt und auch
ein produktives arbeits gefühl hat und
natürlich kann man zu hause auch lernen
das heißt wenn ihr zu hause bleibt und
nicht wisst was ihr machen sollte dann
nutzt doch die zeit zum beispiel zum isi
german gucken und um deutsch zu lernen
oder andere produktive dinge zu machen
das wünschen wir euch auf jeden fall
bleibt gesund wir hoffen dass ihr dieses
video gut verstehen konnte
schreibt uns auch 1 kommentar was macht
ihr schönes zuhause habt ihr irgendwie
könnt ihr die zeit produktiv nutzen wir
hoffen dass es den meisten von euch gut
geht dass es auch euren familien gut
geht und bleibt dabei am sonntag gibt es
ein neues video hier
und übrigens gibt es auch unseren
podcast da gibt es auch viele
neuigkeiten
hört euch den mal an beides verlinken
wir hier unten bis bald